you know we're here in front of st.
Martin's Episcopal Church where that
funeral will take place in just a few
hours people have been lining up all
night to pay respect former Secretary of
State James Baker horseys mr. Bush's
best friend and grandson George P Bush
will deliver eulogies this morning
USA TODAY's Washington bureau chief
Susan page covered both Bush
presidencies this morning she writes
about the contrast between former
President Bush and President Trump
during yesterday's state funeral calling
it quote impossible to miss we all saw
it
well Susan wrote the upcoming book the
matriarch Barbara Bush and the making of
an American dynasty she will be inside
the church for today's funeral Susan
good morning good morning it is the
second big funeral for the Bush family
that this church is hosted this past
year tell us what you're expecting to
see inside in a little bit you know
yesterday we saw a grand state funeral
with former presidents and prime
ministers and kings and queens this is
the hometown church for George and
Barbara Bush this is where the community
that welcomed him when he came home
crushed in January 1993 having lost his
bid for re-election so I think this is
going to be cozier and homier and it's
gonna be more personal than what we saw
yesterday
they've been members of this
congregation for 50 years Barbara Bush
was here every single weekend and
participated in all of their events
James Baker we saw that moving moment
where everand Levinson talked about
those final moments of the president's
life where James Baker was rubbing his
feet and in a rare moment we saw him
break down and start crying what are you
expecting to hear from miss eulogy today
you know they are they have a friendship
that's knitted
in tragedy in some ways because they
became very close friends when George HW
Bush helped Jim Baker through the great
tragedy of his life the death of his of
his first wife and then they became
these this incredibly powerful political
partnerships in campaigns and an
administration Secretary of State when
George HW Bush was president so that the
depth and breadth of this friendship can
hardly be overstated
and I'm sure that in you know the Bush's
cry all the time it is rare to see Jim
Baker cry that was quite the moment yes
it was a beautiful moment Nora and I
were being a little subjective here we
know at this statement to the former
president but from your perspective how
important was his adoptive home state oh
it meant everything it was he almost
escaped from New England because he
wanted to make his own way after serving
in World War two in Texas is where he he
chose to this Texas is where he both
made his fortune built an oil business
and also launched a remarkable political
career here in the southwest you know at
that time that this was where a lot of
gix GIS were moving it was where there
was a lot of growth both in terms of the
population in the economy and it was a
place of opportunity for men and women
of ambition it really was a place where
they built a family and a life here and
the state really welcomed them back I
have to tell you and thank you so much
Susan's great to see you and we'll talk
to you after the funeral as well